yeah
it's Monday [__] wash that [__]
pile that nutsack uncle Joey's coming
all you need is the love juice from your
nutsack to get you through the day uncle
Joey here ready to [__] Rock
understand me listen I wake up on a
Monday with a knife in my [__] mouth
does this is the day you got to taste
[__] down this is the day you gotta set
your mark and [__] enforce it for the
rest of the weekend er stand me anywhere
had a great time at the Cherokee Indian
casino in Oklahoma
if you [__] came by thank you
for making the drive you know I love you
with all my [__] heart but that was
then this is now it's a whole new week
with a whole new set of [__]
priorities we got the hardcore we got
the [__] that stars and we got the
man in the plastic container but who
gives a [__] what we got is what we
ain't got what we lookin for you follow
me
I love morning Wow [__] life it
smells like victory you gotta go out
there if you're leaving the house not
thinking I'm gonna stab my mother
[__] the next today you slip and you
understand me it's [__] elbows and
[__] up so that would hunt do walk
around with your [__] pockets out
like a bunny rabbit huh singing [__]
Christmas carols you better put your
[__] foot on the pedal and get this
[__] going it's time to try the
man and the black container oh this is
the bottom end of it we're ready to
[__] go on a Monday Church tonight 8
o'clock next week the Pittsburgh improv
Thursday Friday sadly I'm making a stop
in Philly I gotta go see my niece at the
hospital want to thank you guys with all
your donations
it means the world to me she called the
other day crying [__] Lindsey's a
savage thank you for donating even if
it's a [__] dower they got no
insurance at all help so we're family
thank you for doing it man I owe you
[__] gonna remember that anyway
it's gonna be a good week man you got
the world by the balls your 24 your 3-2
your 33 and 38 who gives a [__] about
what happened last week it's this week
that matters write your goals down look
[__] in the eye and tell them
suck my dick it's going my way this
[__] weekender Stanley the refs
blowing a whistle in my [__]
direction anyway I didn't watch any
football yesterday I'm gonna dick about
dicks or don't [__] ask me questions
about that oh no not me yesterday I was
[__] meditating with the Kosmos well
football was uh
tremendous chance Tammy that black
container is [__] the same [__] Aaron
Pryor had in this container when he came
back in the last round and beat that
dude up and they never knew the contents
of the container it's the same [__]
container the same container Jose Aldo
drank from it's a container of debt you
follow me
but anyway it's all about you today the
church eight o'clock
be there or be square Wednesday night
the church and I'm around town doing
[__] sex I'll keep you posted
beside that the day is on you man it's
all about you [__] saying about
me I don't give a [__] no [__] you were
young you guys a young walk there
stabbed a [__] do it but [__]
live your dream who gives a [__] you
know what what good is if a dream if you
ain't got no balls behind you gotta let
[__] know I'm imposing my will
like [__] Leonard Skinner than 77 in
Oakland you ain't taking no for an
answer today [__] you
understand me remember every know you
getting it closer to a [__] yes so
hey if you don't leave the house on a
positive note nothing Goods gonna happen
all together nice it be a thief I'll
leave the house I'm gonna crawl in
somebody's [__] window today but what
I couldn't find the [__] window at
least it got you out of the house and
that's the most important thing
container number three huh and see
what's in this [__] square of death
here let's clean this I don't want you
guys to think I'm shorting
like a Chinese people yelling already
understand me that's when you know it's
gonna be a good [__] morning
and the last thing we're hitting is the
star of death aka that star perenial
always putting out reefer the [__]
kills him [__] not to mention
they got the stars in debt now over
there I'm Ventura and Colfax tell them
uncle Joey sanction I'll give you a
cookie or [__] rice krispie treat
this up anyway that's it and that's that
it's gonna be a good day whether you
[__] make it happen enough but at
least you [__] try that's the most
important thing you go down and [__]
flames you just don't go down you follow
me anyway that's it and that's that
you got your mission for the [__] day
uncle Joey pops his head up like that
dude Mission Impossible tells you a
mission for the day now you gotta go out
and [__] set the world on fire on
your own member the world don't know you
dick [__] up cuz you gotta go out there
and take it who gives a [__] let them
put an honorary suit on you at least
you're making the leash and I sit on
that [__] couch thinking about huh Oh
what if what if dick would have dick
there's no [__] what if in your
[__] world you follow me watch that
monkey get out there let these
[__] know what time it is I'll
see you [__] tonight eight
o'clock
ready to rock tip top Magoo wall see you
in Pittsburgh next Thursday night
[__] bring the [__] heroin you
understand me have a good day tell them
all to suck your dick stay black uncle
Joey loves you or they didn't come on my
sellout beat go away